this is Jonathan Ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the Royal
armories Museum in the UK which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and on
this week's episode Jonathan is taking a
look at the weird and wacky guns of
multiplayer shooter OverWatch 2. yo this
game really has some wacky wacky stuff
uh so the closest thing I could think of
for this is this it happens to be one of
our rather nice 18th century
blunderbusses from our collection here
at the Royal armories if there are any
other guns games and mechanics that you
guys want to see Jonathan breakdown let
us know in the comment section below and
if you'd like to help out the Royal
armies Museum and continue to support
Jonathan's work check out the links in
the description of this video right
let's take a look at the weapons of
OverWatch 2.
all right this is an intriguing gun
quite a nice looking design well most
notably has a dual magazine as in a feed
device that has two different types of
ammunition in it kinetic ammunition the
conventional projectile bullet stuff in
the front half and then you've got
similar to something like 40 millimeter
grenades in the background now trying to
think that any power else for that not
like this I don't think now good reason
for that is that it would make the
device extremely heavy and complicated
and expensive and if you've fired all of
your rifle ammunition but you still got
all your grenade ammunition but you
really don't want to find that you're
going to have to swap the magazine and
you can only carry so many of these
things if this was real life which is
not fun and intriguing not I don't think
practical we've seen attempts at dual
weapons many times the oicws brings to
mind the way you have or more
conventionally something like a an M16
with it with a two or three on it so you
get your two types of ammunition on the
same gun that's fine albeit can be a bit
heavy and bulky to try to integrate them
any further seems to not be the way
forward because every time they try to
do it it goes wrong it makes it too big
too heavy too expensive
okay I realized going into this that
we're looking very much at science
fiction fantasy I suppose you'd call it
so this thing is not doesn't really
resemble anything that we have a bit of
a weird shape as well it appears to be
some sort of a cartridge firearm not a
not an energy weapon or compressed gas
or something which you might expect that
it was because this thing shoots some
sort of darts or in fact syringes really
because as I can see from that gameplay
it's doing damage to enemies but it's
healing friendlies so the trigger is
weird we do get sliding or pivoting but
blocky triggers which I'm sure which
this is supposed to be but it looks like
a power tool button and you might think
well you know futuristic setting
wouldn't we have electrically ignited
ammunition and electrical triggers well
it's been tried so far it has yet to
stick and part of that is the lack of
feedback you have to have a certain
amount of responsiveness from from the
trigger it has to you have to you have
to be able to feel when it's about to
break you know often that often the
phrases it's like snapping a piece of
like a slight a microscope slide of
glass or something or should be for it
for a crisp accurate trigger that
disturbs the gun as little as possible a
button is actually if you think about it
not very precise you don't quite know
when it's gonna contact which I suppose
for training might be okay but for
precision Shooters who want to know
exactly when that firing pin is going to
be released it's not very good we also
have no trigger guard which is not a
great thing for safety
double kill
next gun up is a futuristic looking
lever action it's got a loading gate on
the left side not the right side that's
an interesting point actually if we were
designing a lever action from scratched
with a loading gate would we put it on
the left side now because it's not a
standard sort of tactical drills now
tend to dictate that you don't take your
firing hand off the grip a loading gate
on the left side might make sense
overall design very blocky very stylized
but it does have a sort of Old West
callback to the design with the brass
and wood operation wise uh there doesn't
appear to be a fudge here where it
magically goes semi or fully automatic
having said that when it's at the hip as
it were the character is operating it
super fast now if you go and watch some
cowboy action shooting on on the
Internet or wherever they will run these
things so fast they have had the
component parts polished on each of
their lives they'll have a protection
protective wrap on the on the lever so
their Knuckles don't get destroyed
don't get bruised and they'll practice
very very hard and even use reduced
power cartridges and they will slam it
like it's like it's a semi-auto very
very impressive and actually somewhat
possible
right another take on the Magnum
revolver here it's got the faceted
cylinder and maybe General reminiscence
of the Chiappa Rhino or on the table or
something but not close enough really to
say that it's either of those it's his
own thing very stylized of course of
course I'm looking at it thinking how
would this thing work the swing out
cylinder is fair enough and we get we
get this classic flick of the wrist to
shut the cylinder and bits throwing me
off is the hammer which sort of flaps
around but doesn't seem to be connected
to the trigger not as though pulling
through on the trigger is copying the
hammer I don't think I think the gun
just fires and in Recoil the hammer
flaps back and forth this revolver does
sort of I hate this expression but speak
to
um a real aspect of revolver something
called a recoil Shield so I happen to
have here uh just lying around a Smith
and Wesson Model 29 revolver 44 Mag
Magnum and you'll see that it has what
what's typically known as a recoil
Shield these semi-circular flanges
either side of the frame that
cover the back of the cylinder when it's
shut now that's not just for aesthetic
purposes it's called a recoil Shield
because it Shields against rounds
getting chucked out the back of the
cylinder under recoil now this has just
enough of a sort of recoil lug on the
side to stop the cartridges coming out
but they it looks like there'd be enough
room for them to try to come out more so
than on a real revolver where there's
the Gap is not much bigger than the rim
of the cartridge sometimes totally
fictional things can Sparky thinking
about real world firearms
and double
trouble
okay that's fine so very much a western
Vibe too certain characters and their
guns at least we've got a special
ability here with a size somehow the
Stetson is um coming into shot there
there's a line of dialogue particular
sort of focus View and a tumbleweed
comes first so obviously a bit like Red
Dead Redemption is Dead Eye mode but
even more stylized and inspired by The
Westerns where the hero gunfighter isn't
is it a dead eye and is able to make
accurate shots at distance in this case
a headshot
thank you
okay this one is a challenge for me I
think very unusual design it looks to
have a sort of quite an ordinary record
or even gas operated shotgun bolt in it
visible on the right hand side and then
weird lever arms and some sort of
mechanism that is working that bolt back
and forth and I'm not sure there's even
room for that there's an under Barrel
tube type magazine that seems to rotate
now the reason an underbarrel tube
magazine would rotate is to feed pistol
cartridges like the pp19 bizon magazine
that's not what this is this is more
like a shotgun tube magazine so the
rotation seems to just be for interest
sake and I can't see how you get the
rounds into the receiver there's a spike
on the front of that rib there for a
front side which is better than nothing
but there's a current there's a
corresponding Spike on the back of the
gun which doesn't make a lot of sense
other than if you were trying to try to
hit someone with it I suppose but it
certainly doesn't having two sight posts
to line up isn't massive helpful there's
a reason why you normally have an
aperture for a notch or something to
line them up in so I suppose
conceptually it's a combination of a
Magnum revolver and a lever action to
make a sort of massive pan Cannon type
pistol that's pretty unique actually
[Music]
wow well you definitely can't say that
this game doesn't have some creative
guns that's for sure we've got a shift a
manual gear stick shifter knob on the
top there for for a cotton lever a big
box magazine feeding what kind of looks
like I'm sure if they're meant to be
some sort of sport Ball but they are
whatever they are they're a hard shiny
material and they're then getting shoved
down a barrel that has some really deep
rifling intriguingly for me anyway
that's what's called oh it looks like
what's called ratchet rifling ratchet
rifling these are not lead they're not
copper jacketed they're not going to be
gripped by those rifling grooves they're
just going to sort of rattle down along
the grooves and not really get spun in a
way that's going to give you any sort of
stability you can have round projectiles
that are spin stabilized of course
throwing a cricket ball is spin
stabilizing it so that's not the problem
the problem is hard metal or whatever
they're made from is not going to be
soft enough to be gripped by the rifle
of course the game doesn't care about
that as to how it works there's there's
a big arm on the side with a some sort
of repurposed I don't know radio control
car tire or something on it and that
when the trigger is pulled that is
brought into contact with these
projectiles and they're shoved down the
barrel so the Barrel's there to sort of
steer them this is reminiscent of some
toy dart guns some of them use opposing
electrically spun discs to fling the
darts rather than compressed air that's
then released to Puff them out and so
it's actually reminiscent of a toy gun
more than anything else
attackers
right this game really has some fun and
interesting takes on some pretty tired
and worn out game gun ideas I mean that
to sound positive this is It's a rocket
launcher obviously they're quite small
small diameter missiles Rockets what it
reminds me of more so than anything is a
rotary cruise missile launcher on
something like a B-52 bomber it's in the
bomb what used to be the Bombay and now
it rotates one of the missiles I think
they think they drop and then they
ignite and then the next one it rotates
in position drop launch so a little bit
like that I wonder if that was the
inspiration amusingly has the words
flight Direction with an arrow so that
you don't try to put your sort of clip
of rockets in the wrong way around very
stylized design of course with almost a
sort of I don't know ancient Egyptian
esque vibe to it
all right we're getting a little bit
more Rocky I think even than the stuff
I've seen so far we have a pair of sort
of hand Cannon type pistols which appear
to have two barrels but fire four rounds
each so thinking about how that might
work there are super superimposed loads
back in the muzzle loading era and then
even with there was an Australian
company called Metal Storm who came up
with a grenade launch assistant that had
stacked around in the barrel so you
could actually have two rounds stacked
in each Barrel Front One fires first
obviously and then the second not
actually as wacky as it looks what is
wacky of course is throwing your guns
away and magically pulling out two
identical ones these look a bit too
expensive and fancy for you to be able
to carry more than a few this is
something that's known um known in the
trade as it were as the New York reload
which I think comes from a new police
detective whose idea for a Reload back
in the day of revolvers I think was when
you fired your six shots you literally
threw to the ground and you draw your
backup gun so that's that's where that
idea comes from
yeah this game really has some wacky
wacky stuff and so the closest thing I
could think of for this is this
happens to be one of our rather nice
18th century blunderbusses from our
collection here at the Royal armories
the main thing that makes it a
blunderbuss is that flared Barrel now
having having said that this is similar
it's only similar in principle this
thing well it looks to have two barrels
but at the same time a handful of junk
is getting shoved in and I've seen two
fire modes one where it just blasts out
like a shotgun pattern but of junk and
another where the ball of junk is fired
almost like a shotgun slug but breaks up
or your causes like Splash damage
effectively which I suppose reflects
well modern shotgun ammunition can be
shorter it can be slug back in the day
you would build your load essentially in
the breach of the gun from the muzzle
within reason you can put anything in
there and that's that's what we're
seeing here it's it's parking back to
the classic Blunderbuss myth that they
were for putting nails and stones and
bits of glass in now the reason I
grabbed this this is partly an excuse to
show The Collection to you sure you know
by now so this is by T Hatcher and that
name is actually wrapped up in a rather
nice little bit of Engraving of the
Tower of London which is one of our
museum sites this is a very classic it's
an iconic historic firearm we have a
very good collection of them here a
little bit far removed from from what
I'm seeing here
this is looking a little bit more I
don't know grounded in reality is the
right phrase to use but based a bit more
so on stuff that we know and it does
bring to mind
this so this is the m16a1 so this is
vaguely reminiscent of that channeled
through I don't know a Nerf gun or
something there's a folding grip
underneath that that's way off the hand
guard actually
almost looks like a little bit like a
pricatinny quad rail but not really
they're not I'm certainly not aping this
classic perforated handguard from the
m16a1 era well stock looks a bit more
like the carbine butt stock but you
really have to squint to even see that
but it does have the sling Loop a bit on
the top so it's maybe more of an M4 with
a grenade launcher fitted but we'll see
it in action
Kia
okay some unexpected action there so the
carrying handle slides forward for some
reason for reloading so the magazine
does not go into the bottom of the gun
as on the uh the classic AR and the
barrel recoils suggesting that it's
somehow recoil operated now as for the
under Barrel thing of me uh it is
reminiscent of a 203 it's more like some
sort of Rocket setup there are
development efforts toward under Barrel
not so much rocket but guided Munitions
so you'd have the same effect as an
underbarrel grenade but it would guide
itself to a Target that you select for
it I think we're away off that but it
does make some sense to have essentially
a miniature anti-structure munition kind
of weapon almost like a mini RPG as
opposed to a mini m79 on your on your
rifle
all right this thing does
pretty closely for a science fiction
take resemble the MP7 it's even got a
hint of this rear portion of the
receiver in which the sliding stock
slides as it were it's a reinforced bit
of polymer in the rear it's not the same
but it's sort of reminiscent what's very
reminiscent for me is this front cap
here basically like a stopper that goes
in the in front of the receiver just to
sort of close it up and help keep your
fingers away from the hot Barrel so it's
not really required you can sort of pop
that off and it wouldn't cause any major
problems but it is it does lend the MP7
something of its increasingly classic
thing look and it's there on this gun
it's in fact it's prominent it's
enlarged there's some device on the left
hand side that almost looks like a laser
module or something so that would be
conveying data from the from the rear of
the gun to the front so I'm expecting
something computery to go on it might
just be decoration let's have a look
foreign
yeah we've definitely got the the high
rate of fire of the MP7 it's ejecting
cartridge cases very perpendicular to
the side of the gun which is a bit of an
old-fashioned video game mistake the the
ribbon cable on the side is just kind of
flapping around I haven't seen it do
anything yet but this view does make me
realize just how much that weird thing
on the back is a representation of the
butt plate in the closed position on the
MP7 so you're holding it like this it
really does look very similar
whoa
[Music]
all right these these are all very
interesting in their Design This is not
very realistic won't surprise you to
hear me say that but it's uh I suppose
it's a take on the revolver cylinder
Speed Loader system of a cylinder of
some sort of ammunition and there's a
hint of like a some sort of ratcheting
mechanism on the back of the let's call
it a clip and it's it's locked into
place on the feed cover which is then
closed to chamber the clip chamber not
even really the right word load the clip
and then uh a mechanic I've seen before
where hip fire is automatic and then you
use your scope and it's somehow using
all of the ammunition from that device
at once to give you a more powerful
single shot makes lots of gameplay sense
I don't think it makes much Firearms
sense
there will be no next time so that's my
review guys of the guns of OverWatch 2 a
little wary of that one to be honest but
there's an awful lot of interesting
stuff going on join us again next time
you can always go and check out royal
armory's YouTube channel if you like
there's a lot of me on there as ever
please come and visit one of our three
museum sites if you can and if you can't
we have some digital stuff that you can
check out via our website thanks a lot
guys take care
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]